we live in this commoditized we live in
this shiny box world of shiny flashy
things that we're all now constantly
distracted by and all feel like and
while being programmed you need this you
need this you need this and if you
finally get it then you'll be happy and
you're not happy you know but if you get
this you'll be happy if you get this
you'll be happy and simultaneously it's
turned us into a disposable Society
everything that we do in our lives is
basically everything we buy everything
we watch it's all this disposable
garbage I mean it's insane it's speed
speed and speed agree I agree with you
quickly oh speed like I don't need any
more I thought you said Speedy a speedy
greed and I was like which is that too
it's Speedy Green it's 80 degrees it's
like you know it's like Fast fashion
yeah it's insane that you know we talk
about the environment which we need to
talk about we need to talk about ways in
which we can protect it and protect
ourselves and all the animals and all of
the life on this planet which is really
the only [__] miracle by the way
everything else is replaceable or
reproducible it's it's life and life
itself this is the only real [__]
miracle in this you know as Carl Sagan
puts on this little blue dot spinning
around in this vastness and we don't
protect it we we because we've all you
know because Industries all bought and
sold and all of our politicians are all
[__] bought and sold by the
industries through lobbyists and all
that [__] you can take that [__] to the
[__] bank but I'd like to take a
transcript of this conversation to a
bank and just have a woman he said take
it to the bank do you not give me well
we'll put in a safe deposit box and so
and so all these industries have all run
amok and all they care about is bottom
lines it's the shareholders and bottom
lines right against our own invest in
against their own best interest because
if they actually did give a [__] about
their employees and the quality of their
product then they would ultimately make
more money and have more loyal customers
in the long run right but they're all
just like right now I need it right
[__] out it's a speedy greed right
well Speedy greedy I'll sell you beef
grazed in the rain forest meaning I'll
cut down my own lungs yeah yeah yeah
yeah the lungs of the planet totally to
sell you beef today and we'll all yeah
I'm not a I'm not of the opinion that
we'll all die tomorrow but I was
thinking today or I was like there's
sort of a narcissism you're probably
more informed than I am to thinking that
will destroy the Earth I think it's far
more likely that the Earth will destroy
us I I agree with this you know what I'm
saying I think why isn't that the going
Theory though it's like like earthquakes
floods droughts all that stuff will have
fires will happen it'll kill us because
the Earth like an entity is like get
these [__] things off of me or maybe
it's a meteor bath you know I mean by
the way the chances of us getting hit by
another media are way higher than people
really know that's one of those things
like it's like that might actually wipe
us all out well before the Oceans Rise
you say that life uh and the way that
life has been going ancient apocalypse
style and I don't say this with fear I
say this with delight sure as a member
of Life capital l meaning
I used to have a joke where I was like
life will be okay I don't know if we'll
be okay yeah if Zach and Pete will be in
fact I can guarantee that Zack and Pete
will die we will die but life will be
okay and not to get too ahead of
ourselves that's who I believe I
actually am I am a member of life like I
am one isolated member of a thing that
will be okay so in that sense I can say
you will be okay yes but
I think it's it's even if we the new
king and all that stuff give it a few
billion years life life is not gonna I I
completely agree with you I I think uh
that doesn't mean we shouldn't try no no
it doesn't mean we shouldn't try but it
is interesting that the The Narrative is
we're killing the planet when the planet
we're gonna win way robust like the
planet has gone through way way more
horrible shooting but particularly these
meteors these meteors are the equivalent
of like hundreds and thousands of
nuclear explosions right like the Earth
and that's happened before and that's
happened multiple times yeah and life
still found a way not to quote the
dinosaur movie like Jurassic Park but uh
life finds a way and life did find a way
in life it's a family movie and life
will find a way again I completely agree
I think the reason why the narrative is
hey
um we're killing the planet and we
should be worried about that as opposed
to hey we're killing ourselves which by
the way some people do say that but but
the overall narrative but I think the
reason why I think I think the reason
why
I think the reason why is because we
don't we we have taken on a
self-loathing as human beings buddy I
just
destroy like literally people
desire for annihilation but it's not
even just a desire to want to die it's
it's a loathing of self and it's and and
it's and it you see it in the way that
people don't love each other at all yes
that we are completely polarized or
there's or theirselves for sure but the
way that we are polarized we don't we
see the way that a lot of actually
environmentalists have heard this
argument of like we're a disease humans
are a disease we're this parasite of the
earth well kind of but I I like to me I
go wow that's a really I think that's a
really horrible way to view humanity and
not that Humanity hasn't done some
stupid [__] [__] along the way but
we're also pretty amazing we're this in
I don't know how exactly we evolved into
what we are you can say it was God's
touch you can say it's stoned ape I
think it's probably somewhere in between
I do believe in a Consciousness
what's that stone Dave but God was the
weed dealer yeah totally yeah yeah
whatever you know like like you know
divinely uh guided evolution of some
kind whatever the [__] it is but we are
still nonetheless however we got here
were these insane animals that creatures
we are there is no other creature on
earth even very intelligent ones that
deal with the level of anxiety and
stress and depression and all of the
ways we are disconnected from ourselves
each other and yeah and the planet
they're all still kind of doing actual
life yeah where they're either in their
parasympathetic nervous system and
they're chilling and living and eating
and [__] and [__] and doing
whatever animals do animals at large and
then we are the only animal that lives
now by the way now more than ever in the
sympathetic nervous system where we are
constantly in survival mode and I think
that just has to do with the fact that
survival used to be that you know five
like basic pillars of survival you need
to have food water clothing shelter and
tribe those the only things you even
needed to worry about there were no
other worries now granted some of those
things were big worries depending on the
season of the year or whatever can we
find water can we find food but now
we're all I these are my theories but I
think we are are all constantly jacked
into the sympathetic nervous system our
survival mode because survival went from
just finding those things to finding one
thing but getting it over and over and
over and over and over again which is
money money replaced all these other
things if you just have this one thing
you can buy all those other things
but if you have a little bit more than
of that thing then you can have all this
other [__] as well and then I'll be
happier going back to exactly what we're
talking about right so this Pursuit Of
Constant dopamine happiness yes has made
us all slaves to our sympathetic nervous
system in our fight or flight which
makes us all way more unhappy
oh yeah
[Music]